let's talk about Black Panther you are
reunited with your Hobbit cast mate Andy
Serkis yes for this and you guys get to
face-off and we may have a still of that
I'm not sure but it's absolutely yes you
have a faceoff and it is seen it must
have been nice to work with him again
he's a delightful man he's been on here
right yes many years yeah yeah he's a
delightful man very easy he's very good
at his job
I like people who are good at their job
sort of effortlessly they get on with it
they hit the ground running thank you
and that's why he gets paid whatever he
gets paid I know ya know it's tragic
what he gets paid
he's undervalued whatever valued enough
yeah in monetary term it's very good you
got that right away but no it's not and
he's very good at his job and he makes
light work of it you know so I think and
we're both there is there is a it's not
it's not completely true of all British
and all American actors but generally we
go to drama school and generally we come
up in theater and so it's different it's
a slightly different attitude sometimes
to you know if you've got a five-page
scene if you if you've done loads of
plays that's nothing really where is
that you've only ever done three lines
at a time for film or TV or wherever
then I think that can be a problem but I
think British actors wouldn't definitely
not all good we're not all professional
some of us are but but which ones is
this on this is on yeah yeah that is a
cultural difference I think that we are
we are a bit more steeped in theatre you
know yeah and so that and that engenders
a slightly different attitude I think so
just alright we're here let's get on
with it you know I've also sensed over
the years I've said this to many of the
actors we've hadded from UK that there
are good storytellers as a rule not all
but there are there rackin tours they
they've lived a life more and sometimes
I talked to American actors that have
they grew up and they've only been doing
commercials and then they've only been
in television they've only been doing
that kind of work and all of their
stories revolve around being on the set
or you know it's oh yeah you get to slit
lists of a sense that they've lived a
life but yes but I
I would disagree with that yeah me too
because I'm sad somehow been tricked
into being anti-american on this show
all Americans are all the memories think
we're all clever well-educated Britney
weeks Pete you know like that's we're
fooling you with there are dumb people
in the UK and you somehow think we are
all Stephen Fry we're not yeah but it is
the accent that makes them sound smart
yeah I don't think I sound smart at all
but somehow Americans think we do sound
right now I hear you and you sound smart
to me right now
but you suck man you sound classy yeah
little class yeah but like I'm talking
to Kevin and Andy earlier and Oh
dreadful you know and so but ironically
so many so many British actors favorite
actors are and have always been American
yeah it's the grass is always greener of
course but yeah it's not like this
country has any shortage of extremely
talented brilliant artists sort of some
reason you think we're all clever yeah
we're not yeah yeah didn't the gargy
were
you